hallo mein name ist so kann herzlich
willkommen hier heute zu einem neuen
video ich selber quasi rund um die uhr
spent most of that laser luca folgt mir
aus diesem grund habe ich mir gedacht
ich schaue einfach mal was du die sieben
verbreitesten arten von snap chattern
sind und auch die alten machen kontakten
so selber mal gesucht und auch aus
sieben arten direkt gefunden
deswegen würde ich sagen wir haben
direkt mit der ersten art an der erste
typische cnet chatter ist jemand der
einfach alles filmen und festhalten muss
er baut war sie seine story auf wie
einen daily block und das ist an sich
nichts falsches allerdings passten da
teilweise leute echt viel zu viel und
man sie zu 1000 perspektiven einfach nur
von einer tätigkeit ich würde mich
selber so ein bisschen als denjenigen
abständen weil ich ja selber auch
unglaublich viel übers netz steht meine
story pack hab ich zeige euch hermann
beispiel von der hardt chatter was ich
hiermit meine leute ich war
daniel
leute ich hab ich jetzt schon zwei
minuten nicht gemeldet ich bin immer
noch auf der autobahn gibt gas hey leute
schneller und ein bisschen folklore hey
leute ich sitze jetzt nicht mehr im auto
sondern bin jetzt angekommen und habe
noch andere pulli an gezogen das seht
ihr schon hey leute ich finde es auf dem
klo hier kannst du vielleicht ein
bisschen leiter latics gucken ist die
zweite art mutter die ich über die
letzte zeit so ein bisschen beobachten
konnte ist quasi das komplette gegenteil
von der ersten art also bei der erste
hat diese darum dass jemand wirklich
alles irgendwie festhält und übelsten
de/blog macht die zweite person die ich
euch jetzt vorstellen wäre jetzt quasi
jemand der so alle zwei wochen was
brauchst du nach einem rasanten zwei
wochen nichts gebaut
ich werde jetzt demnächst wieder öfters
posten hey leute es ist gerade der
achter november 2016 ich habe jetzt
gedacht ich habe zwei jahre schon nicht
geklappt ich mache das jetzt mal echt
regelmäßiger ich bin da echt vollmuth
ist dass ich das hinkriege wirklich
irgendwie die ganze zeit das netz von
ihm eine story
es ist gerade der 19 november 2022
ich habe mich jetzt leider sechs jahre
nicht gemeldet aber ab jetzt werd ich
wirklich durchziehen
die dritte art von cnet chatter ist ich
würde mal sagen eine bild also ich will
nicht jeden tag mit mitteln der so etwas
macht aber für mich sind einfach so
diese typischen komischen mädels aus
netze die die einfach immer so zwischen
diesen komischen blumen filter und dem
hunde filter variieren und da doch immer
so einfach den jemanden küssen und dann
so ein auf hey wenn so geil ich zeig
euch mal was ich meine
leider sind die vierte art von snap
wetter ist eigentlich in jedem youtuber
mehr oder weniger also ein bisschen
vorhanden und zwar die leute dieses
level schwere plattform zu ihren youtube
kanal benutzt und weil sie sich nur geld
mit ihnen die neues video online system
quasi so leute die jetzt nicht sowas
posten wie wenn sie irgendwie feiern
sind oder wenn sie ihren spaziergang
machen oder wenn sie irgend unterwegs
sind sondern die sich dann meistens nur
melden alle 24 stunden oder alle zwei
drei tages sofern sie halt so oft ein
video hochladen werden sich an ein
solches neues video online also ich
denke jeder youtuber macht das irgendwie
nur bei manchen besteht zu 100% die
story nur aus so was war bei anderen
wie zb bei mir ist das so zehn prozent
also jeder zehnte ist nett sich mal auf
irgendeinen video von mir bezieht aber
ich zeige euch jemand beispiel leute auf
einem kanal ist ein neues video online
hier youtube.com zu der strom kraft da
könnt ihr auf jeden fall mal aus
schicken wird nicht mega freunde
geschildert noch im bett aber ihr seht
hier unten schon meine kanal uhr live
ich hab nämlich neues video hochladen
text auf jeden fall mal aus das mega
kalt draußen kommt an der uni neues
video und euro klar
hier seht ihr den link eingeblendet
klickt er auf jeden fall mal auf
die fünfte art sind die 1 sekunden snaps
poster also normalerweise ist es ja bei
einer story ich bin ziemlich übrigens
gerade nur auf stories also ich bin
ziemlich hier gar nicht auf leute die
etwas privat schicken sondern diese
ganzen arten sind nur quasi auf die
jeweiligen stories von den leuten
bezogen es gibt ja bei snap chat
einerseits die möglichkeit ein video in
die story zu packen uns ja auch die
möglichkeit bilder in die story zu
packen und bei bildern kann mir dann
auswählen ob die von einer sekunde bis
zu zehn sekunden angeschaut werden soll
in 99 prozent der fälle packe ich
eigentlich ein video meine story bei
lich bewegtbild einfach viel besser
finden so ein blödes foto und ich finde
der die story wirkt dann halt auch mehr
wie sonnen blog sag ich mal ich bin das
einfach recht cool diese packen
allerdings auf bildern ihre story und
das ist ja an sich wirklich überhaupt
nicht schlimm allerdings machen dass
manche nicht so lange wie man die
theoretisch brauchen würde um den texten
mit sich das bild anzugucken also fünf
sekunden oder so sondern die post dann
wirklich einfach so bilder mit einem
riesigen text oder mit irgendwie total
vielen details darauf allerdings nur für
eine sekunde in die story man erkennt
dann nichts aber ich zeige euch immer
was ich meine
kommen nun schon zum sechsten match
attax warten dass die leute die mit den
zehn sekunden nicht klar kommen da steht
nämlich auch wieder so ein bisschen im
gegensatz zu der 580 euch gerade
vorgestellt habe also zu den leuten die
einfach nur einen sekunden apps posten
guter kumpel von mir einen youtube-kanal
name sketch sorgt und leiter der
einzigen youtuber die ich eigentlich bin
ich bei snap chat habe weil mir die
ehrlich gesagt alles ein bisschen viel
zu viel kosten wie ich gegen dich
sebastian aber deine sims sind einfach
diese typischen du sagst irgendwas und
dann gucken wann hast du drauf auch
dasselbe schon reichen eben einfach nur
neun auf und packt erstmal die story ich
achte beispiel
diese enormen darauf dass bei mainz netz
wenn ich rede dass das nicht immer
unterbrochen ist und alles irgendwie
passt allerdings machen es viele auch so
dass die einfach drauflos quatschen das
dann einfach alles in die story ball an
aber ich zeige euch jetzt mal weit über
sich er wird überhaupt meiner junge
leute ich wollte nur mal kurz was sagen
und zwar finde ich bei snap steht ist es
echt ultra wichtig dass ihr halt einer
bestimmten person folgt und da war
gerade die zeit weg weshalb man ja nur
diese zehn sekunden
ich wollte sagen dass es für mich sehr
wichtig wäre wenn ihr bei snap chat
wirklich einer gewissen patch sorry zeit
schon wieder weg ich krieg das niveau
hin
was ich sagen wollte war das bei snap
wenn eine person finde ich die snacks
echt mega cool
wer mir halt megabeben tvi das nicht
ganz geklappt also was was ich sagen
wollte war das ihr wenn ihr lieber hier
ist die siebte und letzte achte ich
konnte von snap chatter vorstellen will
ist luca also ich also typisch luca bei
snap chat weihnachten und meine mutter
hat mir irgendwie so ein wunsch stern
hier hingegangen wo ich wohl meine
wünsche daran schreiben soll
einige sekunden später das was ihr vom
video meine damen und herren ich hoffe
es hat euch gefallen wird das getan hat
schreibt mir gern bei uns in die
kommentare was euch gefallen hat wenn
ihr jetzt noch dran seid freunde dann
schreibt mal snap chat und in die
kommentare weil dann sehe ich dass ihr
die leute seid die rede ich das video
bis zu ende geschaut haben das ist immer
cool er sich halt so wäre so die echten
leute sind was sich in letzter zeit auch
mega oft mache ist auf die ersten
kommentare und ersten fragen in den
kommentaren einfach eingehen wenn das
video gerade online ist also wenn ihr
das video gesehen und ihr habt das video
beispielsweise gesehen und kate wird
jetzt vor 20 minuten oder von einer
stunde hochland schreibt einen kommentar
eine frage und vielleicht antwort ich
dann ja hier seht ihr eine smiley
eingeblendet wenn ihr daraufhin könnte
meinen kanal
abonieren ich weiß nicht wo ich nicht
gerade verbeuge wie sollen die eine
kultur wäre auf jeden fall ultra coole
habe ich nicht als neuen abonnenten
dazugewonnen und hier findest du ein
anderes video eingeblendet wo ich
irgendwie irgendwas mache charts